The dimensions of our garden are 12 feet in length, and 6 feet in width. Nice
solving if you found these two answers. Now, we're just getting warmed up, so
if you didn't get it, that's okay. Let's see how we solve. First we replace
this variable l with the equivalent expression 18 minus w. That goes inside
parenthesis here. Next we multiply each term in the parenthesis by w. So, we'll
have 18w minus w squared. Again, we have a quadratic equation here, since we
have w squared. So we want to move all these terms to the left-hand side so our
w squared will be positive. So we'll add w squared to both sides and we'll
subtract 18w from both sides. This gives us w squared minus 18w plus 72 on the
left. And zero on the right. Next, we want to factor this quadratic. So, we
find factors of one times 72, equals 72, that sum to negative 18. These two
factors are negative six and negative 12. We'll set each factor, equal to zero,
so the width can equal six or the width can equal 12. We know the length should
be 12 feet and the width should be 6 feet, since the length is the longer side.
You'll notice that it doesn't matter which value that we use for w. The final
result will be the same rectangular garden. It will be 12 feet by 6 feet. And
as always, we can quickly check to make sure these dimensions are correct. If
we go all the way around our garden, we'll have the perimeter, which is 12 plus
6 plus 12 plus 6, which equals 36 feet altogether. This checks, since this is
what we expected the perimeter to be in our original problem. For the area, we
multiple 12 by 6 to get 72 feet squared. This also checks, which is great,
since 72 was the area of our garden originally.